bienvenue sur diagonale tv dans cette
nouvelle émission spéciale grand
champion de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
avec jérôme on fera ça lui jérôme série
stephen alors on va voir la cette
émission un super champion puisqu'il
fait partie de la grande lignée des
champions du monde d'échecs donc c'est
le top du top la crème de la crème
il s'agit d'un arménien il s'agit du
tigre d'arménie tigran petrossian tigran
martinovic petrossian effectivement
qu'on a souvent appelé le bois plutôt
que le titre du reste oui parce qu'il
avait la réputation d'étouffer ses
adversaires littéralement comme un boa
constrictor voilà alors si tigran % vous
ai dit j'ai des fois aussi un peu le tir
et il était
il est toujours reconnu comme étant sans
doute parmi tous les champions du monde
celui qui avait le style le plus
défensif de tous le plus solide de tous
donc ça va être le modèle de tous les
joueurs qui veulent avoir des partis je
veux dire extrêmement costaud coin
extrêmement solide il ne prenait je ne
peux pas dire qu'on n'est jamais driss
milan prenait très très peu très calculé
il préférait de loin
bâtir une défense solide quitte à
partager le point il se contentait
quelquefois de la nul ça lui a posé des
problèmes du reste puisque à une période
les autorités soviétiques voyait d'un
très mauvais oeil à un garçon qui au
championnat du rss une fois avait fait
15 parties nulles sur 20 sur une grande
partie des garçons pas très offensif il
n'est pas vraiment en valeur les échecs
soviétique et il a dû et volé un tout
petit peu évolué un tout petit peu dans
son style quand même pour devenir
champion du monde
mais il est vrai que de manière générale
il a beaucoup moins de victoires en
tournoi qui n'a eu de succès en match
puisqu'en tournoi une partie nulle
affecte le score du joueur tandis que
dans un match la partie nul n'a pas d'
influence sur le résultat final
oui c'est un gros avantage d'être tigre
petrossian un match puisque il est très
difficile de marquer un point contre
contre lui alors quelle est son histoire
comment comment il arrive comme ça à ce
titre de champion d'italie son
développement il né en 1929 en géorgie
dans la jeune l'urss et il a une
particularité c'est qu'il n'est en la
région d'où est originaire staline donc
c'est une région qui va être
largement mise en valeur à l'époque de
staline puisqu'elle devient un lieu de
détente et un lieu de vacances les cités
balnéaires de géorgie se développe à
cette époque là pour tous les
apparatchiks et le jeune tigran
petrossian ba vi dans cette dans cet
environnement il est entouré de deux
frères qui jouait aussi aux échecs et
d'un père qui qui s'appelle vaart and
d'où son surnom de bach tanovic en
deuxième son père martin voit par contre
d'un mauvais jeu et qui commence à jouer
aux échecs à huit ans parce que il se
rend bien compte que les échecs
professionnels c'est pas vraiment un
vrai métier c'est pas une vraie vocation
le père de tigran petrossian est
illettré il ne veut pas que son fils
loupé l'occasion de faire des études
donc ils le poussent plutôt abandonné
les échecs et à poursuivre ses études
mais en fait il suffit pas le conseil
apparemment le suit le sua moitié
continue ses études mais il corps il
continuait aussi à jouer aux échecs
de toute façon malheureusement tout ça
est interrompue très rapidement par la
seconde guerre mondiale puisque né en
tigran petrossian il ya une dizaine
d'années quand quand elle éclate et
malheureusement pour lui cette cette
seconde guerre mondiale fait de lui un
orphelin par une personne perd et il va
se retrouver seul et très très
rapidement il va être confronté à la
nécessité de survivre
donc il devient balayeur des rues de la
route à cette période remonte ses
problèmes auditifs parce qu'il a eu des
problèmes auditifs par la suite dit que
c'est à cette période ce qui balayait
l'hiver dans des mauvaises conditions et
qu'il était très très pauvres qui s'est
senti humilié à cette période là et
qu'il a voulu absolument s'en sortir ils
sont ses seuls compagnons à cette époque
là ce sont de petits livres qui s'est
acheté un livre de nîmes the beach est
un livre de rudolf pullman et il se met
à les dévorer à les lire avec passion et
il trouve dans le jeu d'échecs est une
sorte de porte de sortie à cette guerre
qui a complètement bouleversé son
équilibre familial
encore une influence de nîmes the rich
client était vraiment le mentor
théorique d'une grande proportion des
champions des années 60 70
oui on a vu des joueurs comme larsen
avait été un très influencé par nick the
beach quoique quoiqu'il fût un joueur
très défensif petrossian aussi il a été
imprégné par ses idées hyper moderne de
contrôle à distance de louvoiement de
prophylaxie c'est quand même lui
peut-être le maître de la prophylaxie
qui consiste à éventer les attaques
avant même qu'elle ait été monté ou
qu'ils aient eu lieu en pratique et donc
petrossian aussi assimilé cet héritage
théorique très important d hyper moderne
des années 30 alors petrossian
suissa carrier en attente du coup il
après la guerre il va il va commencer à
développer sa carrière et il va arriver
assez vite finalement au top du top
mondial puisque il finit par prendre le
titre de bobigny qu'elle a depuis depuis
presque 1948
ça va faire oui presque quinze ans qu'il
est au top niveau bobigny qui les
champions du monde alors par
intermittence parce qu'il ya eu entre
temps thalys 9 mai il va finir par te
ravir définitivement le titre à bobigny
que c'est lui qui met un terme au règne
bottini en 1963 alors petrossian prépare
particulièrement ce match il sait qu'il
est fort match parce qu'il a une
capacité à faire nul c'est relativement
facilement qui lui permet aussi de gérer
davantage son match il sait que bobigny
qui est un petit peu vieillissant il a
lui-même 34 ans à ce moment là ce qui
constitue à peu près le pic pour un
joueur d'échecs
donc il est il est en grande forme et il
sait que c'est son moment s'ils seront
alors juste avant le match pour la
qualif pour la qualification sur un
tournoi en fait il avait dit lui même
genre je crois 80 avant la fin celui qui
ne perdra pas de partie vous aurez déjà
le style de pression
celui qui ne perdra pas de partie
sera qualifié donc et en fait c'est ce
qu'il fait et fait 4 nuls et alors que
les autres prennent des risques et perd
finalement et c'est lui qui se retrouve
face à votre unique alors ils préparent
particulièrement ce match au plan
égyptien
évidemment il connaît les forces et les
faiblesses de votre vie ni qu'ils le
préparent aussi physiquement il fait
plusieurs heures de ski par jour en
géorgie pour se doter d'une condition
physique à toute épreuve qui lui
permettra de tenir le choc physiquement
sur les 24 parties oui il faut tenir il
faut tenir récupérer donc ils
s'entraînent particulièrement pour ce
match et quand ils rencontrent au buzz
vinik bien il finit par l'emporter par 5
victoires à 2 il en fait il a écrasé
quand il a battu assez assez largement
bobigny renonce d'ailleurs de lui-même
au droit qu'il avait en tant que
champion du monde de demander un match
revanche il voit bien qu'il a face à lui
un joueur au sommet de sa forme qui
défensivement est tellement solide que
soit il est obligé de prendre des
risques et se met en difficulté soit il
doit partager le prend avec lui les
trois quarts du temps oui 17 parties
nuls 2 défaites et cinq victoires de
petrossian ça laisse peu d'espoir à bout
de vie unique de pouvoir revenir trois
ans après pour le matin voilà donc
petrossian s'installe et ça va durer
parce que donc il est champion du monde
en 63 et il va défendre son titre devant
le jeune spassky encore un peu jeunes 66
et ce n'est qu'en 69 qui finit par
s'incliner à noter qu'il arrive quand
même en mai mans 72 en finale des
candidats c'est à dire qu'il n'est
arrêté que par bobby fischer pour jouer
le nouveau match face au champion
réunion c'est à dire ce parce qu'ils
nous donc il reste au top finalement on
peut considérer de 1960 puisque déjà il
et il va être
il va être qualifié pour la finale des
63 donc il va dominer le monde des
échecs de 60 quasiment jusqu'à 112 ha
oui quasiment il ya encore des tops quoi
ils restent dans les deux trois premiers
de toute façon même à cette période de
l'art même quand il perd 6,2 contre
fischer bon on sait que time and off et
larsen ont fait bien pire vision perdu 6
et puis même spassky en finale ne fait
pas mieux donc en définitive
petrossian a vraiment tenu son rang il
s'est pas écroulé face à fischer en 72
il a rencontré un jour peut-être un peu
plus fort que lui à ce moment là mais il
s'est maintenu tout le long de ces
années 60 et même au début des années 70
il faut quand même noter tu l'as dit que
c'est le sait le premier champion du
monde à avoir gardé son titre puisque
bobigny qu'il a à chaque fois perdu pour
le reprendre
il est le seul en 66 donc à avoir
défendu victorieusement son titre devant
ce pas ce qui est il faut attendre
karpov en 1981 qui défend son titre
aussi contre cornouaille à ce moment là
dans la période post post guerre la
période post-guerre tout à fait oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai que souvent assez
difficile mais garder le titre est donc
ce donc petroci inconnu pour 7 pour 7
alors il a pour ce style de jeu surtout
je crois c'est ça surtout qui le
caractérise et c'est pourquoi
évidemment on va considérer que l'on
peut considérer qu'il ya deux types de
joueur d'échecs à ceux qui veulent l'
attaquent à tout prix ils ceux qui
cherchent la tactique ça va être plutôt
des pros kasparov ou des profits cher
voilà voilà si le joueur
et puis ceux qui sont plus défensive
beaucoup plus prudent beaucoup plus
profond dans leur approche positionnelle
et qu'ils cherchent moins la tactique
qui sont pas forcément laisse d'ailleurs
un tactile mais ils vont essayer de ils
peuvent être très fort mais c'est pas
l'heure leur tendance naturelle aussi et
c'est petrossian peut-être que karpov
derrière aussi et plus dans la ligne
d'un petrossian ou encore plus loin
kramnik oui donc et qui ont un jeu comme
ça extrêmement solide et qui ne cherche
pas à tout prix à ouvrir le jeu pour le
jeu pour chercher la complexité oui la
légende veut que c'est très jeune son
entraîneur son premier entraîneur au
palais au palais des sports de géorgie
où ils avaient d'autres bbc où il a
commencé à prendre des cours qui
s'appelait hébras lisez là découragés
chez lui toute velléité d'attaqué montré
que de toute façon la tacc menait
toujours une catastrophe veut qu'il
n'était pas question d'attaquer à aucun
moment c'est lui qui l'attaquent en fait
de créer des faiblesses dans son corps
ouvre les portes sans savoir une ouvre
la boîte de pandore sans savoir ce qu'il
ya dedans quand il a visiblement et site
laissait toute velléité offensive chez
le jeune petrossian et ça a plutôt
fonctionné et donc après après 72 il
continue à jouer bien sûr il continue à
jouer bien sûr les olympiades les grands
tournois
il continue aussi à disputer les
interzones haut et comme tout champion
il essaye de se qualifier à nouveau pour
les pour les championnats du monde et
pour éventuellement les remporter mais
il ne il n'a plus la même force que dans
les années 60
et petit à petit donc
il a de moins en moins de grandes
victoires alors il réussira pas comme un
autre champion proche de lui et smith
l'offre qui a été champion du monde
juste un peu avant lui qui avait battu
code unique aussi mais qui a perdu le
match revanche donc il me paraissait
jambiers longtemps mais smith peuvent
lui avait réussi à revenir en finale des
candidats au titre mondial c'était face
à kasparov et c'était en 81 88 par la
2.3 je sais plus exactement mais c'est
exceptionnel puisqu'il avait déjà plus
de 60 ans et c'était c'était tout à fait
colossal de revoir comme ça à 20 à plus
de vingt ans d'intervalle un champion du
championnat londres revenir au top du
niveau avec smith l'ofs
petrossian il n'aura pas réussi cette
prouesse là mais aura par contre lui
dominés les échecs pendant une très
large période en tant que champion du
monde ou encore candidat au titre
jusqu'à 72 donc on va voir quelques
photos oui de tigran petrossian qu'on
doit pouvoir reconnaître parce qu'il a
vraiment un physique très arménien très
très reconnaissable on le reconnaît
assez facilement sur les photos donc ici
il joue avec le drapeau on le voit
soviétique avec la faucille et le
marteau l'invraisemblable eux en
contrats joueurs soient néerlandais
swiebodzin ouais on reconnaît aussi à sa
coupe de cheveux très dans le style de
l'époque
ouais donc on alors voilà ça aussi là on
voit bien ici
téhéran petrossian on le reconnaît un
peu différemment on reconnaît facilement
sur les photos s'il est facile à
reconnaître
alors voilà c'est une photo là en fait
ça c'est une vue de près de la photo
suivante est en train de regarder une
partie en fait un vol sans regard voilà
une photo je crois qu'on reconnaît à
gauche si je me trompe pas il me semble
que c'est al
c'est bien possible ça a l'air d'être
talent sur la gauche celui qui regarde
la partie aussi avec la main sur
l'oreille
donc ici petrossian debout ils sont en
train de regarder alors ça c'est sans
doute une analyse la liste analyse après
une partie les joueurs refont la partie
dans la salle l'analyse pour essayer de
s'expliquer l'un à l'autre un peu les
idées qu'ils auront développé puis
vérifier si quelques coups qu'ils ont
hésité à jouer ou pas été correct ou ou
faux voilà une partie de la mise avec
petrossian est en fait alors on a cette
photo et qui est pas mal qui est bien
parce que on boit un thème c'est un
thème russe sans doute je crois bien que
c'est un tendre ou autre chose
un aide-mémoire exemple s'est créé en
arménien sur le salar d'envoyer c6r many
voilà cette serre mais n'y a plus
précisément de fer russes à revenir
et effectivement c'est un donc comme
thème officiel avec tetro science l'art
évidente qui est une gloire nationale 1
en arménie oui il a une grande postérité
aussi bien en tant que tel parce qu'on
continue à organiser quelques fois des
matches il ya des matchs france françois
min cependant dans lesquelles la mémoire
de petrossian était un peu invoqué parce
que c'est un joueur qui que tu veux que
tout le monde connaît quelqu'un qui est
sur les timbres de son pays est
forcément là une notoriété nationale et
puis là aussi une postérité puisque a
quand même toute une école arménienne
qui l'a suivi
on peut citer pas mal de pas mal de
grands noms oui en rognant il ya
aujourd'hui en copiant fonctionne toute
l'équipe d'armes d'arménie qui fait
partie des plus grandes nations
mondiales arménie où les échecs à
l'école sont devenus obligatoires
l'année dernière où il ya deux ans et
dont le premier ministre se déplace lui
même pour voir les matchs de l'équipe
d'arménie
oui oui tout à fait donc il ya là les
échecs sont une vraie religion en
arménie et c'est sûrement en partie un
peu à cause ou un peu grâce à petrossian
bien sûr voulu tout à fait ça c'est
clair
trait 1 en font date heure de la grande
lignée des grands maîtres arménien ce
magnifique petroci allons voir venir sur
le plateau et on va passer maintenant à
notre parti du jour qui va être la
partie entre donc petrossian et bien sûr
on a choisi cette partie là puisque
c'est quand même l'essentiel contre
votre vinik lors du championnat du monde
justement qui lui a permis de prendre
mais ce fameux titre de champion du
monde qui n'est pas accessible à tous un
nom il n'y a qu'une place
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs qui
auraient pu être champion du monde
on pense à a failli non pendant sa
caresse on pense à flore on pense à
kornoi on pense à mme bronstein les
grands joueurs les très fort joueur les
larsen et autres même beaucoup mais
finalement ce qui sans aller jusqu'au
bout et ont réussi à prendre le titre
mondial y en a finalement très peu il y
en a beaucoup moins
n donc ici petrossian face à vous de
vigny qu'on est aux championnats du
monde 2009 63 et c'est parti avec le
coup des quatre les quatre alors
qu'alexis de bobigny et après ces quatre
g6 on est dans une ouverture de type
indien cirque on veut pouvoir développer
le fou sur un casier set et après le
coup qu'a laissé 3 qui suit depuis trop
chiant en fait votre unique choisi des
cinq qui est la défense
grunfeld alors grünfeld or c'est un peu
différent des ouvertures estonienne
classique puisque au lieu de mettre le
pion des 600 millions des scènes
directement en attaque le centre avec
alors c'est une ouverture tendue puisque
les blancs peuvent prendre en dessin est
sûre cavale et prendre des cinq ans
jouent eux 4 qui gagne du temps sur le
cavalier ce qui oblige quasiment la
prise en c3 et a pris la prise les
blancs un très fort centre de pions que
les noirs vont tout faire pour harceler
afin de le faire sauter de le casser
oui c'est assez moderne comme ouverture
parce que c'est assez paradoxal aussi on
se dit que là les noirs sont en train
d'aider les blancs à se constituer un
centre avec ses 3 des 4 4 oui c'est une
chose qu'on n'aurait pas spécialement
encouragé ni admis au début du xxème
simone prix alors c'est pas la partie ce
qui nous oriente donc se prend car les
prend mais c'est important de bien
comprendre que là les noirs ne sont pas
tombés sur la tête c'est au contraire un
choix raisonné c'est à dire qu'on décide
de laisser aux blancs la responsabilité
de disposer du centre de l'occuper mail
occuper le contrôle et ce n'est pas tout
à fait la même chose et l'occupé et le
maintenir c'est pas pareil
les noirs ont notamment des coups comme
ces cinq qui pose tout de suite un gros
problème puisque évidemment les blancs
ne peuvent pas prendre en ces cinq sous
peine que le pion ces trois tombes avec
échec et perdre de la tour voilà donc en
fait c'est toute l'idée des normes c'est
cette ouverture c'est de laisser les
bien occuper le centre pour pouvoir le
harceler notamment par le coût ces cinq
était donc important et pourquoi pas
plus tard même par le cou aux 5 1 c'est
aussi jouable en tout avec un
harcèlement avec une cavale et qui vient
on va essayer d'oublier les blancs à
pousser ses pions et à bloquer centrale
et harcelés et
et finalement laissé les blancs certes
occuper semble mais de voir le défendre
en permanence donc les occupations
centrale permanente donc des 5 ce n'est
donc pas ce que je choisis petrossian il
choisit quelque chose de beaucoup plus
encore plus moderne presque envie de
dire et joue le ku'damm b3 qui est une
autre variante qui évite de rentrer dans
celle qu'on vient de voir en b3 on
protège non seulement ces quatre noms
ont fait pression sur des 5
donc on oblige quasiment la réponse des
princes et 4 et après d'armes français
katla dame ici protège le pied en d4 et
le pari c'est que la dame est bien placé
alors c'est justement de tout le sujet
de laquelle de la partie est ce que la
dame est bien placé quatre parce que
souvent une dame qui avance trop tôt
peut être chassé par les pièces et demie
par exemple pour imaginer fou de 6 qui
attaquent la dame ne peut pas jouer des
cinq puisqu'elle cavaliers il ya le
fouille à la dame se dessineront perben
pions mais surtout si ce qui aurait tout
simplement dame b 5 échecs et il y
aurait prise du pion 17 sans
compensation pour les noirs avec une
perte sèche donc on peut pas receler la
dame tout de suite
il faudrait trouver par exemple un coup
comme b6 avant ce qui va prendre du
temps et ce qui va finalement pas
forcément être efficace pour chasser
cette dame
donc il ya pas mais c'est pas facile
finalement de chasser cette dame b 4 on
peut c'est aussi qu'elle valait 17 et
cavaliers des 600 gagne trois dames mais
est ce que le cavalier lui même sont là
bien passé en v6 c'est pas clair est ce
que ça vaut le coup pour les noirs
d'utiliser deux coups de cavaliers dans
l'ouverture pour simplement repoussé la
demande est roi où elle sera très bien
aussi
elle peut être très bien et nombre des
trois effectivement derrière et puis
lequel nécessite pas forcément très bien
placés parce que est ce que l'idée c'est
pas des baux d'empêcher le 4 enfin et
c'est bon voilà des questions qu'il faut
qu'il faut se poser avant d'adopter une
ouverture en tout cas parce que beaucoup
de choses sont possibles et finalement
bombay bodini tout ça je m'en fous g7 il
prépare le petit rôle qu'y réfléchir à
tout ça plus tard et là que 4 évidemment
le problème de fou g7 c'est que ça
n'empêche pas on aurait pu envisager
pourquoi pas essayer fou et 5 mai
une fois la dame échec on prend le plan
b c'est bon mais alors que quatre on a
un très fort centre d'opinion comme
d'habitude dans cette ouverture avec
contrôle ici et ben les noirs vont
devoir essayer de le harceler
parce que sinon ils vont avoir des
problèmes ils ont du mal à gagner de
l'espace et un sur à noter aussi qu'on a
quand même ici
alors c'est plus attention à terme
ici on a ce qu'on appelle une colonne
semi ouverte parce que si on met des
pièces lourdes ici on fait pression sur
le seul pion de la colonne effilée cuir
noir le pion c7 est potentiellement les
blancs ont beaucoup de moyens pour
s'attaquer à ce que l'on sait c'est la
dame et le cavalier qui le soutenait en
v5 le fou c'est un qui peut aller henri
iv et la tour pas un qui peut aller en
c1 qu'ils sont capables de mobiliser pas
mal de force là dessus il faut que les
noirs face aussi attention à une
éventuelle poussée en 5 1 qui chasserait
leurs cavaliers qui pourrait leur poser
problème
alors on fait ça c'est possible il faut
faire attention ce genre de coups
puisqu'on aussi on avance les plus
encore un peu plus loin donc ils sont
encore plus facilement attaquable et
puis on sait double tranchant et oui on
rend les pions - mobistar qu'aujourd'hui
on peut jouer l'un ou l'autre mais si on
joue là ça va être plus dur de jouer
l'autre donc il faut faire attention à
bien préparer ces poussées bien en
calculant correctement les les
événements et en plaçant les pièces en
soutien alors donc petit rock normal
faut 2 est maintenant qu a laissé six à
là c'est l'heure pour commencer à faire
la pression la menace c'est simplement
dans prend des 4 donc il faut réagir
qu'à l'e3 est normal on défend en
sortant une pièce alors premier coup
maintenant responsable de bobigny qu il
a un problème pour l'instant pour sortir
ce fou parce qu'il va ou alors si on y
arrive
3 pourquoi pas mais ce qu'on a envie de
s'échanger vraiment qu'entre ce cavalli
si on vit à angers 4 on peut ici sortir
le fou pour protéger des quatre parce
que attention la menace était quand même
prend et des 4e n'est plus défendu donc
on joue faux 3 pour défendre et puis
finalement on en est plus embêté par
câble et jk parce qu'ici si on vous faut
3 tout de suite qu'un léger 4 on peut
même pas enlever le fou parce qu'il ya
le fou g7 qui est absurde et 4 donc ça
perdrait le fou et se foutent important
c'est quand même fou très important pour
les blancs sossou du classement il faut
certainement pas la donne et c'est une
position de type plus ou moins ouverts
ça c'est pas très fermé donc les fous
sont forts calais 17 donc là ça c'est le
coup responsable de houdini qui choisit
donc de différer un développement de ce
fou pour manoeuvrer
donc il fait que lé 17 ce faisant
évidemment il rajoute la pression du fou
sur des quatre mais il bouge tout de
suite la pression la dame mais la menace
elle est simple c'est de jouer cavalier
en v6 attaque
la dame c4 et j'ai un deux trois
attaquants de d4 contre simplement deux
défenseurs cavaillé dame
donc je vais perdre le pion donc
attention cette menace il faut là paraît
fou et trois éclairs fois qu'on a vu ça
c'est si on prend ce coup car les v6
donc un développement astucieux du
cavaliere m6 dès cette db6 maintenant
j'attaque la dame
et puis mais effectivement je montre
plus j'ai bon trois attaques tuant pièce
sur ce qu'ils ont mais qui est bien
défendue 1 2 et 3 avec la dame aussi
puisqu'on peut venir en d3 ou en c5 et
surtout on pourra après cloud et
éventuellement une prise face à la dalle
donc c'est pas très sympa très gênant ou
mais que saddam maintenant en c5 c5
détroit est peut-être un petit peu
détroit est possible peut-être un peu
passif on sait 5 c'est bien puisque ça
on se laisse la possibilité de jouer la
tour avec une action directe de la tour
face à la dame en scène qu'on est bien
aussi puisque bon mais on a un petit
oeil sur recettes ça pétera ça peut être
utile
et puis en sur cette case on peut
toujours plus tard venir en bessin
revenir en b3 on n'a pas de problème ici
en c5 surtout en garde un oeil sur le
pion on est bien la dame et bien c'est
qu'elle est avancé mais pas facilement
attaquable elle est bien placée
le fou est pas y est pas sur les fuites
donc message et ça gêne pas donc fou g4
alors secoué normale après la manoeuvre
qu'ont fait les noirs puisqu'en je vous
faisais 4 je rajoute en attaquant le
cavalier ici de la pression sur des
quatre puisque ce cavalier c'est i
thought des quatre est moins bien
protégés donc là il faut prendre encore
une fois une décision on pourrait jouer
autour des 1 ajoutant un défenseur ou
alors jouer le coup de la partie des 5
bon alors là c'est d'abord ses
responsables puisque on a poussé on l'a
vu un poussette pioncer on peut pas
revenir en arrière
les convois être moins mobiles donc du
coup mais on pose des problèmes en iran
où elle cavaliers il faut faire
attention parce que chacun avance ses
pions
on laisse forcément une casse faible
dans son sillage là en l'occurrence le
pion quand il était un des quatre
contrats la case de 5 comme ça claque
dans le pion de contrôle plus la case 2
5i on peut même dire qu'il ne contrôlera
plus jamais ouais puisqu'il peut pas
revenir en arrière
exact donc il faut être bien sûr que
cette case de 5 peut pas être investis
par les pièces non alors petite
manoeuvre de bobigny quand de temps il
s'est d'abord cavaliers 17
ils attaquent l'adar à noter que le
câble il revient là mais on a sorti le
fou entre temps donc c'est moins c'est
moins bloquant que d'avoir laissé le fou
ici et l'idée c'est peut-être de bobigny
qui sait devenir en le 5 pourquoi pas
et comme ça en cas de prison peut
reprendre un colis ça peut être ça alors
quelle est cette dame à 3 et puis là
encore un coup responsable puisque c'est
fou prend un f3 que choisit bobigny qui
veut même venir ans de 500 à voir
des changes possible pour les blancs et
après fou prend f3 il vient même en d4
c'est une autre possibilité puisqu'on a
éliminé les clarion ne répugnant c'est
nous pourquoi pas mais il y en d4
puisqu'il est protégé par le fou alors
attention c'est quand même deux grosses
menaces il ya une fourchette royal et 13
mai mme royal avec fourchette sur la
tour en plus leur échec leurs autres
objets de se déplacer et ensuite on
n'aurait plus qu'à prendre la dame voilà
et on attaque le fou alors il ya de
grands coups qu'on pourrait citer on
pourrait jouer food est un qui enlève
les deux trucs mais le fou est un humain
pas trop aimé avant un fou ici parce
qu'on bloque la connexion des tours ou
alors on joue le coup de petrossian plus
simple grand roque c'est bien parce que
le roi à roque et donc on a connecté au
tour donc cette tour on va pouvoir tôt
ou tard très vite venir au centre coc se
passe bien on voit bien pression sur le
cavalier centrale puisque la menace
c'est gagné une pièce un tout simplement
vis-à-vis tour dames aussi est donc
plein de plein davantage à ce qu est ce
qui signifie ici que les noirs sont
obligés de prendre le foot est roi oui
parce que les gars pas de casse de
sortie pour le voilà c'est ce que
voulait citer peur c'est qu'il ya pas de
case sortie c'est alors que l'on ne peut
pas effectivement sorti sur aucune de
ces cases qui sont toute emprise donc
toujours notée à l'est les cavaliers
souvent des fois ils se font prendre
comme ça plus dur de coincés au fond ça
arrive aussi mais c'est plus beaucoup
plus dures comme les cavaliers sont ils
ont tendance à passer derrière les
lignes de pions mais pas forcément
revenir à l'avant de cette ligne de
pions exemple bon mais là il ya la
possibilité de s'échanger en plus
contrefout s'était jamais une mauvaise
affaire
c'est pas forcément une mauvaise affaire
mais cela n'affaiblit pas vraiment la
structure de pions blanche parce que on
ramène un pion vers le centre et qui
plus est sur une poussée f5
on n'aurait pas à craindre la prise du
pion leucate parce qu'on pourrait le
remplacer par celui qui arrive trois et
on aurait encore le pion f qui viendra
au soutien que ça nous fait ça fait une
réserve éventuelles et puis une colonne
semi-ouverte qui s'est ouverte mois là
où on a ouvert sa valeur est sûre pour
l'instant c'est extrêmement solide tout
ça mais ça peut être un thème aussi
parce que regarder on peut
envisagée dès h 4 h 5 pour casser ça et
pourquoi pas mettre la deuxième tour en
attaque et on a deux tours attaquante
bon ben ça peut ça peut créer une
attaque on sait jamais on n'en est pas
là c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
toujours avoir l'esprit cavaliers b6 à
yop
le cavaly cas alors il a travaillé bien
parce qu'il est venu la ligue mineure il
est venu là puis après il est revenu ici
et maintenant il revient ça fait quand
même 1 2 3 4 3 4 5 ou cinq coups en cinq
coups sûrs qu'un village où un tiers
découdre on s est énorme alors mais ils
menacent chaque fois il a créé des
menaces donc on lui pardonne voilà là
ils attaquent attention c'est dangereux
parce que si on perd ce fou c'est pas
bon attention parce que ce fou quand
même est un monstre regardée comme une
année super diagonale ici et puis s'il
le faut et échanger qui avait une
reprise du pion f2 en e3 le fois ci sera
une autre diagonale des fous j'ai story
notre diagonale intéressante c'est celle
qui part de chis exactement si on
prenait ici avec le temps on aurait une
belle diagonale au side attaque là
qu'ils avaient le droit derrière et
safed et ça fait beaucoup de noms il
faut pas laisser faire ça donc dame b 3
logique alors à noter encore à regarder
le fou est sûre cases noires et on may
la dame sur case blanche
tant qu'il y avait faute de couleurs
bonbon savais pas trop où la m mais là
là c'est clair toujours si vous risquez
vous essayez de voir sur quelles
couleurs en général des fois il ya des
batteries dans mes fonctions efficace
mais sûr mais souvent la dame et bien
sûr la couleur opposée pour pas dire
toujours et on peut noter aussi que en
investissant la case b3 mais si on
défend ses 4 mai la dame se place aussi
sur une diagonale
oui c'est wade qui est sensible voire
critique exacte tout à fait les noirs
peuvent peut-être à un moment à voir
dans l'idée de jouer
c'est un coup des coups aussi au jouet
100 ensuite ils ont peu et envisager des
coups comme des six avec les chats
qu'elle a découvert échec de la dame et
puis
et après il perd en déprises pénible à
gérer donc la dame en v3 et bien en plus
l immobilisme peu ce cavalier qui
ciblent je pourrais faire sauter le pion
bessette c'est pas forcément dans l'idée
est donc ce serait sacrifice de pions il
faut y réfléchir à deux fois
et regardez vous avez vu comme la dame
est venue sur les couleurs opposées du
fou par dés le coup suivant des noirs
sur quelle couleur est le fou de 15 mois
est sûr qu elle sur quel type de cases
on peut mettre la dame au regard des
poufs rien comme ces prêts si on met la
dame sur casse blanche alors que le fou
et sur 15 nord à noter qu'on à connecter
les tours ça c'est important
ça nous permet de jouer vers le centre
avec les deux tours donc de les mettre
en action cette dame pourquoi pas
pourrait venir ici proposé un échange
plus tard ryan kavanagh mais pourra
proposer peut-être plus tard en échange
à 4 cette dame est bien placé pour
l'instant en plus elle peut aussi cette
dame protéger la puce et ses 600 cas de
prison pourrait reprendre de la dame
voilà le genre de joueuse the elle peut
aussi et s'il rentrait dans le camp
adverse se lançant laventure jouant h3
ouais on pourrait éventuellement
pourquoi pas pour attaquer la chaîne
depuis la base
et oui c'est une menace qui donc il faut
tenir compte parce que ou valve pions là
qu'on ne peut pas protéger le pion ainsi
la tenue h3 faudrait jouer
4 mais si on joue f4 on affaiblit un peu
4 bon voilà c'est dit m
d'ailleurs le coup suivant finalement ne
plus trop si on y va dans cette idée aux
joues à gstaad donc bon on protège la
maj 3 las casas 3 puis en plus on
commence à attaquer à noter un peu comme
on a cette fameuse diagonale aussi dame
ici si on pousse h5 et comprend ce sera
délicat de reprendre du bief à cause de
cette découverte
donc si on prend du pillage par contre
on a une colonne ouverte contre le roi
qui est bloqué du côté
ici ouest non qu'il pourra pas aller à
gauche donc il suffirait de trouver un
moyen de mettre la dame ici pour
quasiment pour menaces et mat
donc attention hein secoue h 4 donc ça
explique le coup suivant de vote unique
à stein ont très vite confirme la porte
en la question pas de questions de te
laisser ouvrir comme ça d une colonne
gratuitement il va falloir travailler un
peu plus pour ouvrir la colonie on peut
retrouver d'autres solutions pour la
colonne on pourrait envisager pourquoi
pas un f4 f5
c'est possible avec pression sur g6
obliger les noirs à prendre et puis
ouvrir la colonne pourquoi pas mais il
faudrait avoir des motifs d'attac bien
précis parce que c'est long plusieurs
coups et en attendant même temps c'est
quand même ce qu'ils jouent mais c'est
quand même ce qui joue f4 effectivement
f4 et avec ça peut avec avait dit
d'arrivée or deux idées ils payent avant
lui de 5,5
parce que l'idée de 5 c - avancer les
pions que de boucher aussi l'avenir de
ceux de ce foulard et puis ça reste très
fortement l'espace de manoeuvre n'est
que 5 menace quand même si ce qui est à
calculer mais pénible on peut jouer
aussi effectivement eu six en brisant f7
enfin reprendre sans doute la reprise la
dame protège et puis cgeci ce qui est
faible mais après on adams et 2 qui
attaque directement examen pour avoir
dame ses deux bouts alors
l'hommage est tout simplement tour
julien avec pression sur g6 oui il ya du
jeu pour les blancs avec bien sûr le
coup h4 et menaçant le coin 5 c'est
effectivement le pêcheur 4 mais ça
commence à affaiblir l'europe voyez que
le pion le pion g6 et moins jeunes
protégés dans ces conditions ici et f4
commence à être agressif donc votre
vinik réagi extrêmement rapidement il
joue sans doute un coup correct qui est
le coup le 6 mai un coup affaiblissant
encore c'est à dire que la caisse qu'il
pourrait jouer d'autres fait d'ailleurs
il signe ici il peut leur ait pu tenter
aussi ses six ça c'est possible pour
essayer de commencer à faire des
échanges au centre et ouvrir la colonne
devant le roi blanc et ouvrir exactement
ouvrir ici par ce tour c'est 8 on aurait
ouvert la colonne si on arrive à
échanger ce pion contre le roi blanc bon
ceci dit laurent blanc il a une super 15
ici il est peinard sur il peut aller
jusqu'au bout dans le coin il sera
faudrait calculer ses six parce qu'il ya
quand même fou prend b6 et il ya une
perte de pions éventuellement il ya
plein de choses à faire
donc il joue aussi ce mode unique alors
aussi sa double avantage c'est que un
bon baisse à contrôler un peu mieux
5 si on joue au f5 et bien on peut
prendre du plomb et sans casser le rock
et en cas de prix ces dames qui prend là
perdu un pion pour rien mais ce coup qui
attaquent des cinq a un autre souci
c'est simplement des princes le 6
petrossian saute sur l'occasion
il prend à près d'1 prend 1,6 et d'en
prendre s'ils finissent choisi
d'échanger n'a pas trop le choix s'il va
perdre de temps et après ce point de 6
il a cassé la structure des pions noirs
regarder cette structure s'est éclaté et
un pion arriérés angers 6 kg en arrière
et angers sicile que parent isolé en
russie ce exact donc deux pions faible
aussi cg 6 contre 1 seul point faible du
côté blanc c'est le pion f4 il est un
peu faible soutien quand même ici ce qui
pourrait être attaqué par le fou et
et cette attaque se faire des led de la
tour donc c'est un pur un peu faible
mais vu que c'est un pion doublé il est
déjà double est faible déjà en tant que
structurellement déjà à la limite c'est
bien pour les blanchir vous pouvez
changer sion contre les deux bons donc
là les blancs quand même un petit
avantage structurel du fait qu' ils vont
pouvoir quand même attaqué tout de suite
puisqu'ils jouent tour à g1 attaque le
pion g6 tout de suite donc déjà et non
pas le loisir on est d'essayer
d'attaquer la faiblesse f 15 il faut
répondre
donc il ya aussi un avantage de tempo
pour les blancs qui attaquent les
premiers ça ça compte donc 3 h c'est
comme ça c'est bien moi je sais tu
protèges et pourquoi pas maintenant on
peut envisager plus tard fou h 6 mai les
blancs continuent avec leur initiative
les blancs continuent avec le coup
cavaliers bessin alors gouvernance il
peut bien ce conclave est simple parce
que je peux pas vraiment prendre en
essais 7
pourquoi parce que j'ai tour c'est lui
qui cloue le cavalier donc c'est pas ça
la menace non la menace en fait c'est de
venir en d4 pour attaquer coib le pion
faible de 6 points faibles 6 en
attaquant à la fois la tour ici et la
possibilité de venir sur la case g5 avec
un échec pénible qui dit pions arriérés
dit kass faible devant le plan arriérés
la casse g5
c'est un superbe avant-postes pour le
cavalier et puis le pion aux sicile et
les faibles maintenant il a besoin
d'être défendus absolument par une pièce
il peut pas être défendue simplement par
action puisqu'il ya plus de pions autour
de lui vous voyez comme un joueur ce
confinement vise l'autre côté en fait
c'est là ça c'est la magie de
des cavaliers donc tour f7 de la part de
bobigny qu'elle arrange ou entouré vii
boni bombay commence à protéger sa
septième rangée
même si la prise ici n'était pas à
l'ordre du jour comme on l'a vu mais ça
protège quand même ça commence à
protéger puis ça évite plus tard aussi
des pénétrations de la tour sur la 7ème
parce que on pourra très vite aussi
jouer des fous prend cavaliers suivi de
tours 7
et qui pourrait faire un échec si le fou
davanture avait bougé donc voilà l'idée
de tours f7 c2c classique aussi bien
comme ça quand vous êtes en défensif
d'essayer vous même de protéger votre
propre deuxième rangée ou si ici
septième rangée donc le coup suivant par
contre arrive forcément c'est quand même
qu'avec des quatre attaques le pion aux
6 c'est pas possible de laisser ça donc
il faut jouer le coup suivant tours 8
mais ces passifs c'est passif et puis
c'est toujours un peu embêtant de
mobiliser une plus grosse pièce en
défense que l'adversaire ne mobilise en
attaque elles et blanc mettre un
cavalier dans la balance et les noirs
sont obligés de mettre une tour c'est un
peu embêtant c'est embêtant
et regardez l'astuce maintenant up call
les trois magnifiques donc vous avez vu
le cavalier pouf menace ici et
finalement pour venir la wii alors là
vous êtes si on a vu l'explication
précédentes on comprend l'idée c'est
simplement de deux ponts de benin c'est
de venir sur un magnifique avant-postes
angers 5 échec au roi est sûre
fourchette est toujours un petit oeil
sur le pion de 6 et en plus bien sûr on
a en plus toujours une petite attaque
sur le pion de 6 donc c'est une
magnifique à ce point qu'à venir et puis
dans le futur si on a poussé au sein
qu'on aura la case 4 qui pourra venir
s'offrir qui elle-même ouvre la porte à
calvia santa fe il ya beaucoup de
possibilités pour le cavalier on dit
souvent qu'il faut pas bouger plusieurs
fois la pièce dans une pièce dans le
début de partie
bon là on est déjà dans le milieu de
partie donc ça se justifie mois et puis
il faut bien comprendre que la
lecavalier dans cette position c'est une
bonne chose de lui de le faire aller
vers sa meilleure case et puis ça s'est
fait sans perte de temps puisque à
chaque fois il ya une petite menace qui
a obligé les noirs à jouer des coups
passif donc ces quatre coups de
cavaliers ils sont un peu passées comme
il est
la poste n'a pas été une grande
difficulté et noir n'ont pas pu faire
grand chose en attendant exact donc
bonne vinik comprend tout ça bien sûr et
joue le quasi forcée fourrage 6 alors
fois ci c'est un double intérêt un
j'attaque la fameuse fait là aussi une
petite fille blanche attaque un peu f4
et puis je contrôle la casse g5
j'empêche évidemment la fourchette jean
pesce le cavalier de venir sur cette
case de deux raids
alors on pourrait envisager de venir en
cinq attaquants la tour mais ça ne mène
nulle part parce que si je viens à 1,5
bon ça mais nulle part si ces joueurs là
monsieur j'attaque la tour on voit la
tour alors à noter que sa menace aussi
tout reprend gc ca donc il faudrait
jouer un coup comme tout réussi ce qui
protège g6 qu'un seul dans ce cas là
mais petroci ans estime que son avantage
est meilleur s'ils jouent le coup quand
même cavale et j'essaye de toute façon
ça oblige mais vu qu'il ya une
fourchette tour ça oblige la reprise par
fou et maintenant simplement tout prend
voilà on prend du attention on prend
bien de la tour pourquoi on prend pas du
courage parce que on aurait laissé un
pion passé ici protéger les protégés qui
ont passé sévère symptôme qui plus tard
pourra devenir une vraie menace
donc c'est un ce sera un vrai souci
quand même oui ce sera un vrai souci
imaginons qu'on échange toutes les
pièces oui le roi blanc va devoir garder
un oeil oui pour tout le reste de la
finale sur ce pion ne pourra jamais
s'éloigner
et pendant ce temps le roi noir pourra
aller croquer les pions blancs un parent
tranquillement on crée des menaces les
menaces qui seront de l'autre côté là on
ne pourrait aussi prendre du point mais
il ne faut pas reprendre avec un pion
sur une 15 faible on ne ferait qu'aider
les noirs à réparer leurs structures de
pions oui si on prend du plomb f
on bouche l'action de la tour en plus
vers la tour n'attaque plus rien on a
réparé la structure des pions blancs
vous avez bien ils sont ils sont plus
doublé oui mais ça ne permet pas de
garder le dynamisme dont il faut prendre
de la tour parce qu'on garde une
pression sur j'insiste donc on peut
envisager
de doubler ici et en plus cette tour a
aussi la possibilité de venir en 5 ou
pourquoi pas en c5 ou pourquoi pas en b5
plus tard par exemple peut imaginer des
baies 3d à 4d à 5 pour déstabiliser le
cavalier et venir titiller ses pions les
obliger à bouger de façon à créer des
faiblesses donc c'est une tour active
c'est mieux que les autres options donc
avait laissé quatre ici de la part des
noirs alors là ici l'idée des noirs
c'est moins de menaces est entre
guillemets de prendre ici qui pas une
vraie menace
on peut prendre on peut reprendre du
pillon et on a une structure extrêmement
solide contre les pions attaqué du côté
noir c'est l'idée ici de beaux d'unique
c'est pas tellement ça c'est plutôt de
recycler son cavalier de l'amener à la
défense sert que là ils jouent pas bon
ben il faut trouver les moyens de leurs
amis en jeu essayer de le ramener en jeu
donc ici simplement dans un premier
temps tour des jeunes de petrossian qui
se presse pas et la menace c'est de
prendre le pion g6 si j'ai six tombes
le reste va tomber m le chien quotidien
donc ça ça va être difficile donc il
faut protéger touches à 8
il a simplement roi ces deux ils
améliorent petroci entre améliore la
position de son rang il ya ces deux îles
et bien en c2
il commence à s'avancer en prévision des
changements ultérieurs le roi commence à
devenir une pièce active
en comparaison le renard ne peut pas
bouger ainsi viande g7 par exemple
pourrait prendre le top 5 puisque le
pion g6 et clouées sur cette tour
pourrait prendre aussi une plongée 6 du
reste et on peut aussi prendre le plan
g6 directement c'est encore mieux
puisque sa veine tout donc on peut pas
avec le roi noir s'améliorer alors que
le roi blanc si il peut commencer à
venir vers le centre et ses des coudes
avance dans les finales ultérieure avec
deux pièces encore sur l'échiquier donc
b6 alors b 6
parce que quand même il y avait une
petite menace d'aller prendre là bas un
ça à peu c'est des choses auxquelles il
faut dont il faut tenir compte
alors des six détroit en chasse
lecavalier a voté comme un des pions ici
sur la couleur opposée à celle du fonds
caravelle et des six attaques le pion
peu 4 mais simplement f3 regarder ça
c'est extrêmement solide d'autant que ce
pion f3 ne peut pas être attaquée par
les noirs puisque le fou contrôler il
faudrait donner une qualité ce qui n'est
pas dans ceux dont il n'est pas question
bien alors maintenant tour 17 les noirs
et c'est maintenant d'activer leur
propre tour ici en des sels d'essayer de
voir dans quelle mesure ils peuvent
essayer pourquoi pas de jouer un rôle
sur ce la colonne des 1 alors que bombay
ici il y avait rien à faire un f4 était
pas t'es pas attaquable et ce qui est
intéressant à noter c'est que on connaît
la technique anti cavalière qui consiste
à priver les cavaliers de bonnes cases
oui et si on regarde le cavalier noir on
se dit bon il pourrait ensuite revenir
aux recettes pour chasser la tour g5
certes et ensuite qu'est ce qu'il fait
oui j'arrête pas de point d'entrée dans
le dans le camp blanc moyens c'est à
dire qu'ici oui mais c'est ce qui va me
peut se passer d'ailleurs mais
effectivement le ici ce qu'il n'y a pas
d'avenir rdi peut pas venir en bessin
qu'ici à la tour prévient ans et 4
passes quel point on peut venir e4 parce
qu'elle peut on y arrive c'est parce
qu'elle puis un nom qui peut nuire à vii
ce qui est bien ça peut chasser cette
tour c'est ce que tu me signale
effectivement et ce que tu dis c'est
qu'évidemment la taxe est pareil là
aussi il sera pris par le pion là il
sera pris par le pion par celui là même
en passant par h600 ensuite y'a pas de
il n'y a pas de sortie et si bien réussi
s'il est toujours pris celle ci dans ce
cas oui il est dominé ce qui a sapé le
dominer en fait il a il reproche connu
s'échanger contre le foot ça aurait été
peut-être un tout petit peu moins bien
un tout petit peu mieux alors donc
tournant maintenant il a fini son
travail sur la colonie
petrosyan qui ramène sa tour ils voient
que maintenant que nous aurons joué ici
c'est presque plus possible de coulisses
et ici en fait de faire coulisser 7 pour
donc il choisit de la recycler et sans
doute maintenant il veut peut-être
passer par cette colonne d essayer de
voir comment il peut continuer à
titiller le camp de renvoyer comme ils
cherchent des petits avantages petit à
petit donc tourner des huit de bobigny
qui alors votre vie ni simplement lisse
et aussi nos colonnes sinon rien sur des
on peut enlever le cavalier il ya la
potentialité d'échanger des tours à
quatre tables s'élève donc c'est ce
qu'on a vu alors le cavalier bien ici
parce que il d'abord il sur la couleur
opposée au fou donc pour ce n'est pas
plus mal
et ils comptent 3 le banc la classe de
5e c'est pas grave y'a rien mais surtout
la casse g5
donc on peut plus revenir sur la plage
c'est le coup à 4 aussi était
intéressant quoique petrossian prépare
minutieusement la finale de pions qui va
sûrement arrivé après les quelques
échanges le pion b5 et fixer là il peut
plus avancer
le clan mais 5 est fixé mais peut-être
aussi on veut pouvoir jouer à 5 ouvrir
et avoir une colonne de pénétration dans
le camp noir pour venir titiller plus on
tousse et 7 ce qui s'appelle une attaque
de minorités c'est à dire on lance une
minorité de pion à l'assaut d'une
majorité ici deux pions contre trois
dans le but de créer une faiblesse un
pion à rire et options isolé ni d'ouvrir
une colonne tout à fait attaques de
minorités c'est exactement le thème 2
contre 3 de façon ouvrir les lignes et
puis mangé le pion de plus finalement
par une série de pressions alors
maintenant que les noirs le muscat et
c'est bien mais ils font plus du tout
pression sur f4 que faisait la tour donc
ce fou devient libre mais beaucoup plus
mobile et tout en en étant ans et henry
mais pourquoi il revient sur sa case de
départ mais en définitive il a autant
d'actions sur f4 oui et puis maintenant
il ya d'autres possibilités
par exemple se recycler en b2 ou voir
ans à 3 3 me sur ton bleu alors là il ya
une diagonale intéressante quand même
puisque maintenant qu'ils aient plus de
fou noir de cases noires suite le
manoeuvre de kabylie est tout à l'heure
il ya le fou blanc en mai 2 va pouvoir
dominer
la grande diagonale est là quand même
une grande importance puisque ça
restreint notoirement aussi bien les
mouvements du roi que les mouvements de
la toile et noir ne peuvent pas doubler
sur la colonne j'ai par exemple ils
peuvent difficilement défendre
nous-mêmes ramener le roi vers le centre
droit n'a plus accès au centre alors la
bo de vigny que bell sans qui voit là
que pour l'instant il est passif un
moyen compilé l'offre trancher dans son
camp et ils jouent quasiment sur trois
lignes
il n'y a qu'un seul pion qui est sûre la
4e alors que les blancs jouent sur
quatre lignes ils vont avoir un fou
mobile canton cavaliers qui pour
l'instant ne l'est pas trop on a vu
qu'il était coincé par par les pièces
bon bien une absence de deux plans en
fait peu de l'unique ici c'est de tenter
une simplification un peu un peu
hasardeuse puisqu'il joue le coup eux 5
alors c'est hasardeuse parce que il
ouvre lui-même des lignes souples au
film en aussi c'est sur la couleur
opposée au fond difficilement attaquable
sans pénétrer sans faire pénétrer les
tours mais c'était aussi potentiellement
une faiblesse enfin en toute fin de
partie
bon il essaie donc de se séparer de
cette faiblesse mais finalement cette
faiblesse
elle est équivalente option doubler ici
donc en échangeant contrôle qui ont
doublé
finalement est ce qu'on y gagne quelque
chose c'est pas tout à fait sûr il a
sûrement espoir de pouvoir faire
pression sur le pion à trois quand même
alors il peut espérer effectivement
après une prise de que ce pion ici soit
un peu faible et de doré attaqué sur la
colonne f1 pour attaquer c'est tout à
fait possible
exactement hélas en maintenant
petrossian revient mais c'est pas même
position puisque les noms ont joué cinq
alors il revient sur la case de 3 alors
peut-être que les normes potes ne peut
même pas tout on fait tout simplement je
sais pas si j'aurais pu tenter alors on
peut pas bouger un d'ailleurs parce que
les deux tours font pression sur g6 un
jour sur trois peut-être qu'il veut
menacer
à 5 peut-être qu'il veut contribuer à
faire pression sur le bloc de pions de
ce côté là en ayant le faux qui bravent
dessus russie ont toutes les pièces
noires sont un peu immobilisé donc la
bonne unique avait choisi de se séparer
de se faire cet échange qui ont faible
contre pions faible en quelque sorte
et après fou prend f4 finale impulsion
manche un peu mieux parce que on tape
maintenant sur ces 7 ce qui n'était pas
le cas donc c'est cette devient
impossible
lampions et 4 est devenu un pion passé
le pion 1,4 et maintenant qu'ils ont
passés qui peut menacer d'aller à dam de
ou tard et puis surtout nos pions sur
blanc gernez plus un seul sur noir ce
qui était le cas tout à l'heure et qui
bloquait justement un fou alors que la
monf ou est totalement actif à noter
aussi que ce fou domine totalement le
cavalier adverse puisque toutes les
cases de sortie sont sur la trajectoire
du fou ça veut dire se fout a droit de
vie ou de mort sont ce cavalier il a
installé un péage sur la route du
cavalier oui c'est un péage sur la route
exactement donc tour 17
mais moi j'aurais préféré le coutour 17
plutôt que cette manoeuvre simple bon
bref à leur tour d2 et la bombe échange
de tours ont proposé tout reprendre
apprend donc l'avènement vote unique par
contre avec cet échange est peut-être
content parce qu'il a libéré sept tours
parce que cette tour protéger g6 mais il
ya plus de tours à l'attack donc je peux
la bouger le devient mobile
attention quand même parce que j'ai une
pure entreprises ici par le fou et
l'échangent détour arrange aussi
petrossian dans le sens où la faiblesse
du pion c7 se révèle jusque là ils
pouvaient pas le prendre le pion ses
sept puisque de toute façon son roi
était en c2 et qu'un coup aussi simple
que tours s'est vite cloud est le fou
sur le roi et le gagner donc les
échanges vont quand même avantagé les
blancs qui profiteront des pions à b et
c qui sont sur casar exact je t'en
prendre appui sur ok donc alors ici 3 2
alors regarde remarqué comme le roi bien
sûr la case blanche
pour pas gêner les éventuels trajectoire
de son fou et il y en a quand même
protégé la toute petite faiblesse
blanche f3 une difficilement attaquable
mais qui reste une petite faiblesse
quand même un b3 beaucoup moins faible
puisque moi pas trop comment et noir
pourrait venir
voilà les impôts le charrie plus
important pour les blancs c'est surtout
laissé aucun point d'entrer ici on voit
que la tour blanche tour noire ne peut
pas arriver plus loin que des quatre
dont elle ne peut rien faire d'utile
pour l'instant dans des cas de fraude et
venir un bec à dallas tout ça est très
longtemps dans les blancs peuvent
manoeuvrer
donc c'est 5 de la part des noirs bon
ben j'enlève la prise du fou très bien
mais j'ai regardé tous ses pions sur
noir la main c'est ça ne fait pas
plaisir quand même parce que j'ai un fou
ici de glace noire
imaginez à quel tour s'échangeait se
fout il va ramasser
il joue l'un et tac tac tac il ramasse
et comme les pions noirs bc ne peuvent
pas avancer à cause des pions de la
pousser à 4,2 tout à l'heure et détroit
oui ils sont ils sont figés là ils sont
bloqués exactement ils sont bloqués et
regardez le fameux à 5 c'est aussi
l'autre l'autre menace et qui est
toujours là maintenant qu'on a enlevé un
défenseur de bêtises on peut jouer à 5
ce qui va affaiblir c'est parce que
c'est plus dur d'aller attaquer à 700 le
pian que après prise d'aller attaquer b6
parce que b6 on va pouvoir passer par là
colonna et et venir là alors qu'on n'a
pas de colonne pour aller chercher le
pion à alors là on se dit mais blanc
donne un pion mais en réalité les noirs
peuvent pas réellement le prendre à 9
pas décemment legrand ne peut pas
prendre ce convoi très concrètement il
suffirait de cheveux fous ces sept pour
le récupérer
mais au-delà de ça vous pourrez jouer
tout au tout fou csn et de racheter
surtout tour
c'est un tour à tour ses seins ou alors
tu auras un et puis on ramasse tout
on va ramasser tous ses pions ils sont
tous extrêmement faible sur tous devenus
très faible en un tour de tourner ce
genre de coups de bélier sont pas
vraiment des pertes de pions parce que
ça casserait totalement les structures
des pions ici de reprendre donc tour 17
apprends b si ça prend mais six essais à
hisser leur regard des tours 1 voilà
c'est ce qu'on disait maintenant les
blancs ont trouvé un moyen d'entrer dans
le camp noir et donc pourquoi pas
devenir enlevé huit après pour titiller
le pion b ou devenir raciste
pareil pour quitter aussi le cube est à
noter que ce fou et très bien les
empêche la tournée là même de venir
défendre donc roi g7 les noirs ici
ramène le roi pour être près du centre
ce qu'on veut ce qu'ont fait les blancs
depuis longtemps donc il faut qu'ils le
fassent à leur tour mais c'est peut être
un peu trop tard déjà puisque après tout
raciste comment puis-je protéger ce pion
fondamentale le plan b 6 s'il tombe ça
nous fera quand même un gros pions de
moins avec comme souci c'est une
toujours faible et 1 kg ont passé ce qui
veut dire une position extrêmement
compromise donc le seul coup tomber
cette il faut protéger
c'est le seul coup admis mais voyez ces
passifs
c'est donc ces noirs restent passifs
malgré les manoeuvres réussi tour à 8
maintenant des petrossian donc en jouant
tour à six il oblige tomber cette qui
est mal placé maintenant tour à 8 je
peux pas enlever la tour de nouveau
puisque ça serait cette fois tourbe
éviter là on pourra même plus venir
protéger donc roi f6 je me rapproche du
centre tours c'est 8
regardez comme petrossian pénètre sur
case blanche
il va pouvoir venir faire un échec qui
va repousser le roi noir est attaqué à
la fois b6 est toujours gardé une menace
sur des six qui oblige la tour noire
rester en 17 mois la baisse icg si c'est
exact
le g6 à droite et messi sa gauche vous
voyez comme petrossian manoeuvre
habilement pour pénétrer le camp noir et
créer des
menace de plus en plus difficile à
contrer ça n'a l'air de rien la ta
petite attaque de minorités le
basculement de la tour en 1 ça monte à 6
à 8 c 8 mais c'est quand même une belle
manoeuvre cavaliers de 5 de la part des
nord à leur avantage de cavaliers 5
c'est que ça empêche bien sûr pour ces 6
voilà et simplement tranquille
petrossian se pressent pas encore une
fois il augmente la capacité de son roi
ici en jouant roi ou trois c'est
quasiment ce gang c'est quasiment une
loi tout en valeur la menace peut être
de ce monde presque dire que honda se
font prendre 5 droit prend imaginons
qu'un col et blanc le noir je tiens je
sais pas en venir aux coups comme ça at
il alors il faut prendre reprendre ça
fait peu en un fou prend pour apprendre
6 on attend c'est ce qu'on ferme la
porte c'est la zone matt track b6 à
takashi c'est surtout mener 4-1 f4 échec
et mat en plein centre de l'échiquier
il n'y a pas d'échec de la tour noire
puisque le pion b3 tout est pris toutes
les pièces contrôle attaque le roi et
toutes les cases sont priés qu'on peut
se faire mater mais au final on pourrait
me faire bouger scène pour empêcher
puisqu'il ya prise et si on joue la tour
on se fait prendre tous les pions on
fait d'abord on prie on prend d'abord si
l'odeur ce doute puis après l'autre pis
aller retour et donc re trois cavaliers
maintenant tous ces six échecs quand
même donc le roi ici regardez ne peut
pas monter donc on est obligé de
défendre de descendre au f 7e et là
c'est leur non seulement c'est une
poussée de pions mais sa menace sa
menace une fourchette accessoirement
c'est quand même important parce que
c'est difficile à part c'est difficile à
paris et puis ça va permettre aussi aux
rois de monter tranquillement celui
ouvre un chemin
voilà donc voyez comment les blanc
dominent cette situation par petits
coups c'est toute la technique de
petrossian qu'on voit ici petits
avantages cumulés cavaliers fuite est
quasiment forcé regardez maintenant tout
est tranquille c'est implacable petit
échec ou valleroy 3 pas à chaque fois
les coûts sont mauvais coin c'est très
difficile donc il faut garder le contact
et le cavalier sinon il serait en prison
leur comportement on a contacté siens
projet 7 et simplement on continue 4 on
améliore la position de noix et on peut
menacer devenir des cinq et on peut
menacer de niro c6 et de prendre tous
les pions
si le roi danse ici c'est très pénible
pour les regarder la différence entre le
roi blanc qui est extrêmement mobile et
ce comme actif extrêmement au contact de
ces 2 6 points d'avancé pour un noir qui
est totalement une copie digne et la
force du pillon passé et là aussi c'est
qu'on est obligé de décider de tout
faire pour l'arrêter qu'il est
extrêmement puissant donc là les noirs
doivent réagir il le fait très bien
votre unique puisqu'il faut b5 alors là
l'idée c'est de baies de secret soi même
puis ont passé sur d'où ces quatre
gardés en cas de prise on pourrait
presque poussé et non pas reprendre
puisque le fait de pousser menace très
vite d'aller à dame
il y aura même
avec échec et surtout sa menace de faire
dame sur une case blanche non pas une
case noire puisque la casse est un il
est contrôlé par le fonds blancs bien
sûr si je reprenais voilà mais la menace
est vraiment c4 donc il faut quand même
faire très attention à ça donc tour66
sur ses six ans la tour c 6
ceci dit ça n'empêche pas vraiment ses
cartes on pourrait quand même tenté c4
on pourrait quand même tenté c4 alors
sur ces 4 on pourrait envisager quand
même on peut pour quand même prendre
peut-être on peut aussi trouver déclara
train tout simplement on joue b4 et puis
finalement les pions sur l'immobilier
mais on a un pion passé qui est embêtant
alors si on prend on peut envisager des
4 et qu'on arrête ce pion tout est là en
fait c'est pas dur il suffit de jouer
fou c'est un pou b2c fini s'est bloqué
et on a deux pions passé donc c'est pas
très bon donc tour c6 est bien là
maintenant le problème c'est que on ne
peut pas pas défendre de pioncer cinq si
l'on joue alors on peut tenter éclats
les 17 peut-être mes cahiers 17 6 heures
si sa cavale et 17 ou même roi des cinq
ou six au cours des cinq ou même fou 3
plouf
tout simplement donc c'est extrêmement
de passif oui c'est que passif on menace
rien et ça perd donc en fait la beauté
unique se résigne ivre ou 3 f 7 il
essaie de colmater les brèches en
activant son rang et voit bien que la
différence c'est que c'est le roi blanc
qui est extrêmement actif
donc après tout repenser 5 des salles il
a perdu un pur net
il a un pion passé contre lui et après
cavaliers aussi ce tour des 5 3e set est
fou et trois de nouveau se fout regardez
domine encore une fois ce cavalier qui
ne peut pas bouger
et ils n'ont pas trop ou simplement même
que faire alors là quelle est la menace
maintenant des blancs c'est de continuer
à faire pression inutilement déjà ça
immobilise la tour et on peut tenter f4
f5 briser sa puisqu'en cas de prise
c'est le pion à stein qui est faible et
on aura encore un deuxième puits ont
passé ici en h4 donc tourbe et 8 ne se
presse pas les trois anciens toujours
des petits coups tour des six alors tour
des six peut aussi laisser la voie libre
à roye des cinq attaquants lecavalier ou
valve cavaliers et après derrière c'est
le pion g6 qui peut être en prise ou
leroy qui vient au contact du pion b5 et
la tour est d'autant plus immobiliser
donc b4 maintenant de la part des noirs
on se demande bien ce qu'ils cherchent
parce qu'alors le problème c'est que
mulally peut même pas meilleure attaque
et on fout le domine toujours tour à 6
alors il joue par des singes du tout
raciste l'idée des blancs dans ce type
position si sam sa menace tour à sept
puisque le roi lorsqu'elle sera obligé
de descendre le plus de possibilités de
rester tombé 5
c'est le cas en fin de tour un chien qui
check 3,8 et maintenant f4 encore plus
d'attentes la part du vote unique qui
joue le 57e coup par roy et fuite pour
essayer d'empêcher l'avancée ne peut pas
après f5
ils abandonnent après avoir souffert
pendant 25 coups oui on pourrait voir la
suite rapidement
donc c'est la serbe en bout de ligne
qu'on peut regarder simplement la suite
l'a pris c'est quasiment forcé or
apprend le cavalier est attaqué lui par
le roi alors imaginons un coup comme des
chèques aux cavaliers en g7 mais
simplement pour jouer roger 6 à noter
que la tour noire peut pas faire échec
en b 6 à cause du fou et 3 alors on peut
pas faire échec en d6 effectivement
puisqu'elles font ou 3 et si les noirs
prennent ici sur la case e 5
on peut simplement jouer au regard des
tours ou la tour f 7
échec au roi est ovale roissy ambiant g8
on prendrait le cavaly avec échec et on
a une grosse pièce de plus et il reste
des pions largement suffisant pour faire
dame
et si on vient en 8 très simplement il
suffit de jouer fouet 4 et le cavalier
est perdus c'est sur l'échec
évidemment on me suis relâché comprendre
car il ya eu droit et surtour 4 par
exemple aussi c'est pareil empreintes
qui revient mais toujours en fait on a
deux pièces en prison et c'est le roi
qui prend pas la tournée surpris si on
garde le contrôle du fou donc on a une
pièce de plus avec tout ce qu'il faut
pour gagner puisqu'ils encore deux pions
notamment ceux plus en plus et sur la la
colonne h sur la même couleur que celle
du fou donc on pourrait même échangé les
tourments bref il ya de quoi largement
l'emporter
petit avantage à la fin mais suffisant
et on a vu comment petrossian a joué les
chaque fois des petits coups donc s'est
pas départi à grands sacrifices s'était
départi de micro avantage qui été
cumulées et c'est vraiment typique du
style de prikro sienne et c'est comme ça
qui est le méchant tout nu il y en a
l'impression que chaque coup ils
avancent ouest il avance son avantage
qui était mineur et devient minimes qui
était minime devient tangible à l'orgie
devient sensible de sensible devient
intéressant et l'intéressant devient
important et on a l'impression que
chaque coup de progress en sng secouer
sa position s'améliore tandis que son
adversaire est pas en mesure d'améliorer
huile sa position c'est c'est assez
impressionnant lorsque empêcher
peut-être aussi en pariant d'être un
très bon tacticien et contient identit
avait mis sur des puces aux tactiques
qu'il pouvait bien sûr sortir des
grandes combinaison mais il ne cherchait
pas absolument y chercher plutôt ces
styles deux parties à un gain de micro
avant ta joie très grand champion du
monde petit grande petrossian sans doute
un modèle pour tous les joueurs qui
veulent
jouant aux échecs de façon prudente et
réfléchie et éviter qu'ils n'ont pas
dans leur durée dans leurs gènes de la
fibre du grand attaquant qui est prêt à
prendre tous les risques pour gagner y
compris le risque de perdre d'ailleurs
eu assez de talent d'ailleurs qu'on
disait que le jour où il fera il
acceptera de faire des parties du dit
parce qu'il prenait tellement de risques
qu'ils perdaient trop de partis en fait
ils perdaient les parties qu'il aurait
pu simplement annulé ouais
et pour le coup pour le goût du risque
ce qui ne risque pas trop d'arriver à
petrossian c'est les partis qui sont
venus très intéressante je pense pour
des amateurs parce que les notions
stratégique et notions techniques qui
sont développés dans les parties elles
sont utilisables dans beaucoup de
parties d'amateurs un tout ce qu'on a vu
là je dirais il ya bien sûr il ya des
coups qu'il révèle de conception très
profonde mais il ya des choses dont on
peut faire faire son expérience et
notamment l'activité qu'on a vu
l'activité des pièces en finale
notamment du roi on a vu comment cette
simple supériorité de l'activité du roi
le problème que pose le pion passé et le
fait de créer des faiblesses comme on
l'a vu à 4 a sign crédit faiblesse et
profiter des faiblesses le parcours du
cavalier jusqu'à la meilleure case pour
s'échanger contre le fu garde-fou contre
le cavalier parce qu'il est meilleur
mais tu les pions sur les cases blanches
pour profiter de l'activité du foot
cases noires une attaque de minorités
une entrée de la tour il ya quasiment
tout le bagage technique et où le
langage du fort joueurs exactement
donc voilà pour cette émission spéciale
tigran petrossian merci gérard de
l'avoir accompagné pour cette émission
sur les champions et puis je vous donne
rendez vous sur une autre émission des
gones altérée à bientôt
au revoir